[Music]
thank you
this is reese's pieces we named her that
because her orange and brown spots
reminded us of the candy
and i work from home so reesey and i get
to hang out a lot and whenever i get
stuck on a particularly
thorny r problem i talk to her she's
kind of my sounding board and she
invariably gives me some sage advice
and the very biggest piece she gives me
is to be lazy
this is actually how she sleeps it's
kind of ridiculous
so what i mean by being lazy is you want
to make it as easy as possible for
future you
to do as little work as possible to
understand what you're writing today
so this this describes a lot of
different things
you're basically trying to be consistent
with your own work you're trying to
have some patterns that you follow all
the time so it makes it really intuitive
for you to figure out
um what you're doing next and this this
starts with the project structure
so unfortunately this is a little
smaller than i'd hoped i'm sorry
this is a example a very small project
but it does have some problems
i don't know if you can see it but
there's a there's a file called
monolith.r
it's enormous imagine in four months
from now you're trying to find a
function in this enormous file it would
be pretty difficult
and there are data files in here that
have names that
are completely non-intuitive if you come
back to this later are you going to be
able to tell what's going on
probably not you will be sad
so in the in the interest of future
laziness you can reorganize this just a
little bit do a couple minutes of work
to save yourself
possibly hours of work later so what
i've done here
is cut uh split up that big r file so
that some of the you can tell where the
global functions are where the help of
functions are what the main analysis is
and just by the names of these files you
can kind of tell
where you might go to find something if
you're looking to update or add new data
i have also added a new data file uh
data structure here so and i've renamed
all the files so that the names
themselves
will give you a clue as to what's in
them you don't have to remember what
this strange esoteric file name is if
you name your files in a way that it's
easy to tell what's in there without
having to explore them automatically
so just this little bit of work today is
going to make your life a lot easier
later
which is exactly what my cat had
suggested
in addition to that to that being at the
structure level for your projects you
also want to do that within your
individual files you can pick the
structure that works for you as long as
you're consistent so that you can tell
later kind of what you meant and if you
always structure it in the same way or
you almost
order it in the same way you're going to
remember what all this means
my preferred way is to have library
statements at the top then source
statements
object definitions function definitions
and then the code at the bottom
obviously i'm going to be creating
objects and functions along the way but
the global ones go at the top so i can
find them easily later
and then at the statement level you want
to make these human readables as well
so a machine can read either of these
equally well but a human being going
back and needing to alter something
the second one is a whole lot easier to
read so for the rest of this
presentation my cat was so lazy that she
wouldn't pose for me so the rest of this
has
uh beautiful images from the internet so
please enjoy
so more bits of advice that she's given
me
i don't know if you guys have seen this
before this is my favorite gift ever
try things it's not always going to work
as you know but try them anyway
and if they don't work try to land on
your feet
learn from it walk away like a boss you
meant to do that
ask for help if you need it these are
some of my favorite resources google is
obviously a great first place to go as
well
if you have a local our users group or a
local our ladies group you can actually
ask in person as well
keep your claws sharp learn new things
at all times again lots of resources
here
i definitely recommend our ladies and
our users groups to learn these in
person because then you can ask
questions and things like that
try to learn new things try to keep on
top of trends and it could make your
life a lot easier
hang out with your friends again i'm
going to plug for our ladies it's my
favorite group
but there are lots of places to do so
online as well
and finally bask in the sun enjoy the
fact that future you is going to be much
more happy
if you've arranged for current you to
design your projects in a meaningful way
thank you very much
you